I love that you're so confident this
interview you brought out reading
material no I didn't you know what I'm
gonna be on you want me to be honest
with you this is nothing to do this is
not the pre-interview I carry this
because I'm so nervous
last night finish your sentence I flew
in from Spokane Washington and I took an
uber home and I asked the guy was out of
batteries and asked the guy to plug it
in for me and then I left the car and my
phone this all I have is an iPad my
phone is in the uber Mike it's not funny
my phone is in the hueber and what I was
going to do is and then I called that
uber support and I got no support and
then so this is the driver this is if
you know if you know here's said so I
don't find you his name is David because
his name is David and he's driving a
Honda Accord and he has you have my
phone
you have like fun he's in LA I want him
to I went to uber support I got no
support right right I have Conan's
support yeah and that would get me my
phone call I have I can't take calls I
can't do anyway that's out of the way
you know let's talk about this is the
service we provide for our celebrity gas
it's gonna get my phone David this is
basically now at this show after 24
years has become a glorified
lost-and-found
you